in the city nine is all why I told
you I break you well you gonna help me
or not
monsters are coming cleanse this city
and blood and Fire
it is a new day you can't have the truth
unless you feel a true calling
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new Gotham
footage they decided to drop it like the
day after I did my preview but a lot of
the stuff that I talked about is in
there the thing that I really want to
talk about though to focus on is the
Batcave this picture here is actually
one of the first depictions of the
Batcave itself is from Batman number 48
way way back in 1948 before he had the
Batcave he had like a trophy room where
he and Robin would talk about their past
adventures it didn't start out that way
though so they actually wrecked condit
so that Robin so that the Dick Grayson
Robin would take trophies from each of
their adventures after they would solve
a mystery it would go in the trophy room
so that's how Batman started
accumulating all these really weird
objects the most famous ones I feel like
are the dinosaur and the giant penny
which are now in the Batcave proper the
Batcave itself didn't debut in the
comics it actually debuted in a really
old serial
there was a weekly Batman serial back in
1943 they would release weekly episodes
and theaters where you slowly got to
know about Batman the Batcave debuted
during the second installment that's
that's the first time his underground
cave appeared throughout the early years
that they would just like adjust the
placement of certain rooms like the
trophy room got moved to a separate
place if you remember in the Michael
Keaton Batman film much more recent you
see Vicki Vale walking through looking
at like the armor and all that stuff
that that's like their representation of
the trophy room he makes up some story
about being a collector but but it's
actually a bit tongue-in-cheek because
he acquired those as part of his Batman
adventures that's why I think once
Alfred and Bruce make it into that
secret underground room you know
whatever the Batcave looks like they'll
probably find a few trophies you know
just a place that'll inspire Bruce to
start keeping things from his adventures
but over the years as you can see it
liked it for example this is the new 52
Batcave Batman has continued to expand
things this is actually pre new 52 this
is even larger this takes a lot of
inspiration from the classic dick
spraying Batcave it's just that so many
people started writing in about how they
were interested in learning more about
the Batcave
the editors started telling the writers
to go crazy so the Batcave just got more
and more elaborate over the years the
reason that they've kept a lot of the
really odd objects in the modern comics
I think is largely due to people like
Grant Morrison who take the approach
that all of Batman's adventures in all
of the comics that he's ever appeared
actually happened even though you know
each writer is only on a single title
for like a year or two at a time so
Grant Morrison like when he came on and
he did Batman and Robin whenever he
introduced Damian Wayne he was like all
these Batman adventures that he's ever
had they actually happened so he would
have had trophies from all these so he
doubled down on the trophies you know
especially with the giant penny in the
dinosaur I just think it's really nice
that he pays that much attention to
detail I mean I think most writers
nowaday try to do that but that's not
always been the case for the longest
time though the actual Batcave had had
no real continuity as to when Batman
started using it in his own timeline it
just at a certain point he had a cave
underneath wayne manor where he started
hiding out it was even a time when he
allowed tours to come through and look
at his trophies this is obviously still
in the era of the trophy room this is
like pre Batcave though but at a certain
point he was like okay I have all these
tours coming through I need an actual
secret place where I can be Batman and
actually it wasn't till after a crisis
on Infinite Earths and you know like
like DC rebooted all of its characters
that a writer said Bruce Wayne actually
grew up at Wayne Manor at you know like
in all the modern stories like as far
back as most people can remember it's
always been his home his family's home
but it didn't start out that way
originally it was just a really nice
house that an adult Bruce Wayne bought
one of the first big times that they
actually told the story of Bruce finding
the cave underneath Wayne Manor and
turning it into the Batcave didn't
happen until 1994 it was a Detective
Comics number zero he was right around
zero hour in the comics right around
that big event Thank You Hal Jordan in
1998 in shadow of the bat number 73
there was a big earthquake that almost
destroyed the entire cave it changed the
structure in a really big way and then
later during no-man's land during that
story arc he started using the satellite
bat caves I think has a really little
kid that the most notable time I
remember Batman using a satellite
Batcave was during nightfall
after Bane broke his back and he kind of
slunk off into the shadows and Azrael
took over they made it seem like Batman
fell off the map like nobody knew what
was gonna happen to him or or if he was
ever gonna come back spoiler alert
Batman always comes back but he had just
gone to one of his safe houses which is
kind of like a satellite Batcave if you
remember during Final Crisis - when they
killed Batman off I mean they didn't
kill him they sent him back in time but
you get the idea
Dick Grayson took the manse
the bat he moved the bat-cave so that it
was underneath the Wayne foundation so
the bat cave itself is actually a pretty
complex idea but there is no one single
bat cave but the bat cave prime like the
original bat cave is underneath Wayne
Manor you I mean you can view it that
way at least in the current continuity
just to explain where the the giant
dinosaur and the giant penny came from
the t-rex came from a story called
dinosaur island and it was a Batman
number 35 in 1946 the dinosaur itself is
the is animatronic though it's not an
actual live dinosaur the penny was
originally a trophy from Batman's
encounter with a penny obsessed villain
named penny plunderer that was in
world's finest number 30 in 1947 there
was also a story called the thousand and
one trophies of Batman from Detective
Comics number 158 in 1950 you know a
long long time ago but as the story
implies lots of trophies in the Batcave
some of the really cool ones are two
faces original coin
Deathstroke's sword victor freezes
original gun a piece of kryptonite I
mean he also has the kryptonite ring of
course and all of the old versions of
his own bat costume and all of the
Robins costumes here's my big question
for you guys how do you want them to do
the Batcave on the TV show do you want
it to start out as like a small room
that Bruce like slowly makes bigger and
bigger their caves all beneath Wayne
Manor so I'm just assuming that he's not
going to find everything right away I
love that there's that creepy symbol on
the door it's not an owl so I'm a little
disappointed because I want them to do
court of owls but I feel like it's
implying that there's some sort of
mythology that Bruce is going to learn
about some deep history that his family
is tied up in that's one of the best
things that shows like Gotham can do
where it's like you know we can't have
him put the cowl on but we can build the
mythology out in a really meaningful way
that's really what makes TV shows fun
for me shows with really deep mythology
to explore speaking of which I'm still
working on Doctor Who and I have that
Robin video to do so I'll try to get
those out in the next couple of days be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm gonna try and make it down to VidCon
I was supposed to be down today but
things didn't didn't quite work out
YouTube actually just announced they
they fixed the mobile app if you're on
your mobile phone if you go to my
channel page and you click on this bell
it'll tell you when I upload videos but
you but you have to enable alerts on
your phone like just
fault alerts for the YouTube app the
Android version in the iPhone version
are just like a little bit different
right now so I think that they're still
rolling out fixes over the next couple
of days but everything should be great
pretty soon let me know like which of
you guys actually watch videos most the
time on your phones I'm always curious
how people find my videos like I try to
make them so that they look a little bit
nicer like on really tiny screens
speaking of Batman videos though I'm
trying to finish my Arkham Knight
gameplay videos hopefully that'll be
done by next week because Game of
Thrones just released a new episode and
I want to start playing that but while
you guys wait for that to drop you can
click here to learn all about the
villains that are coming to Gotham
season - and you can click here to learn
all about the new inhumans coming to
agents of shield season 3 they're
basically they're doing secret warrior
so it's gonna be a lot of fun thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow